triporteur by porter ou rallonger pour
2021 v-league aux locations propose
trois nouveaux modes de transport 500
vélos à usage personnel vont rejoindre
la flotte de location qui avait
transporté à vos enfants les enfants
d'amis des animaux des courses ou des
petits meubles pourra aider des amis à
déménager ça se fait sur des trajets
assez varié ça permet de compléter des
trajets donc vous pouvez partir de chez
vous déposez vos enfants à la votre
travail puis le sens renard faire des
courtes donc c'est un visage très
polyvalent faire découvrir aux
franciliens le vélo électrique à moindre
coût l'on sait il ya un an le service
met à disposition dix mille vélos
classiques les locations peuvent aller
jusqu'à six mois renouvelé trois mois
progressivement 5000 vélos
supplémentaires sont en train d'arriver
courant de l'automne et 5000 vélos à
nouveau vont arriver début janvier
jusqu'à février mars 2021 ce qui
permettra d'atteindre 20 mille vélos en
termes de flotte et ligot location
aujourd'hui on a 95 % de nos usagers qui
sont satisfaits du service qui est mis
en place
les préinscriptions pour le triporteur
ont débuté hier mardi 15 décembre
les souscriptions pour le bi porter et
le rallonger débuteront printemps 2021
la location de ses modèles coûtera 80
euros par mois pour une durée de trois
mois